hello everyone and welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we will
create a fully functional ecommerce
website using javascript and some other
technologies as well you guys will enjoy
today's video because today we'll
implement javascript to its actual use
will create a fully functional ecommerce
website so before we begin make sure
that you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
so without any further delay let's get
started
so this is the website we are going to
create in today's video here you can see
we have an html web page with the
navigation bar to take the user to
different sections of a website
i hope you already know that we have to
create several web pages for a single
website to make it a fully functional
website
we have to create these pages separately
in different html documents and then we
have to provide the links to this
particular home page for directing the
user to various locations of our website
if you see here in the navigation bar
we have several options starting with
our company's logo so comfort learning
is the company's logo here we have an
icon of the book to let the user know
that this website is for learning
so we'll see further in this video how
we can use these logos and all then we
have links for several other web pages
of our website that are not working
because we haven't added these web pages
till now the reason for this is
we don't want to make this project a
long one we want to finish it quickly
and we want to give you guys a basic
idea of how to use javascript and other
technologies to create a fully
functional website
next up we have a cart button over here
on clicking it opens the cart with items
present inside it and the user can
either clear the whole cart or proceed
further to buy all the things they need
right
following this card button we have a
background image over here with the card
present over the image
the card says find your favorite course
here now you guys might have guessed
that this website is for buying courses
and the user can buy some courses here
which they want to study
this shop now button is completely
working and if we click on it it will
take us to the courses catalog
where we have several courses present to
choose from we have eight different
courses present here you can add as many
courses as you want or as many products
as you want
so we can add any of them to the cart on
taking the mouse cursor over any image
you can see it gives us an option to add
that particular product to the cart
right
if we click on this add to cart button
you can see it says in cart it means
that we can't add any specific course to
the cart more than once
we can later change the number of items
in the cart but we can add a course only
once from here let's add some courses to
the card and then we'll see if it's
working or not
so we'll add few courses we'll add this
one so it says this course is already
present in cart similarly this course is
also present and we can add this course
now we'll move to the cart we will click
on this cart button and you can see we
have all the courses present over here
now if you notice here we have these
small arrows present right we can click
on these arrows to change the number of
items we can either increase the number
of items or we can decrease the number
of items as well then we have a remove
button over here and if we click on this
remove button you can see the course is
removed now we can remove any number of
courses we want and we can also increase
the number of products in our cart
following it we have two options over
here either we can clear the whole cart
or we can proceed if we click on this
clear card button there will be no codes
present in the card and the total price
will change to zero in that case fine
so i hope you guys must have known the
task by now it's clear and seems
effortless right but these small things
take a lot of precise coding and
attention to work smoothly
so let me show you guys one more thing
before we move on to the coding part
if we reduce the size of a web page or
we can say if we remove the size of our
browser you can see the size of website
also changes if we make the browser
similar to a phone you can see we have
got a menu type of thing over here and
if we click on this we are getting the
options here we have home categories
pricing and about us right so these were
the options present in the navigation
bar we can get them inside a particular
menu using css we'll see how it actually
works
so a website is responsive right we'll
do it with the help of css so let's move
on to the programming part now
so here we are in the vs code we have
all the images already present inside
the images folder in our system so if
you want to see you can see here we have
all the images present over here
and we have four different files we have
app.js we have
index.html products.json to add products
and we have style.css to style all the
elements fine here we are in the html
file some of you guys may think that
html css and javascript were fine but
what's up with the json thing we haven't
heard of it in the previous videos
so let me tell you guys json stands for
javascript object notation just like we
create objects in javascript json is
also used to create objects like name
value pairs and later we can use these
objects to retrieve that data in a html
file in simple words to add an item to a
cart we need to store it somewhere to
get the data related to the object
and then we can add those items to our
cart so json is used to transmit the
data between a server and a web
application
we need to store a product somewhere so
that we can use them when added to cart
so you will get to know more about it
while working on it basically so for now
if you know enough about javascript
objects then json will be easy for you
guys because the syntax remains almost
similar in both the cases that is in
javascript and in json
so let's start writing the code now here
we are in a html file and we have
already linked all the files over here
you can see here we have used font
awesome library for icons we'll use on
our website you have seen that book icon
we have used in our logo part and
several other icons like the cart icon
etc so we'll include those predefined
icons in a html file using this
particular library
to include this specific library you
don't have to do much of a task go to
google search cdn js dot com slash
libraries
slash
font awesome
go to google and search for this and
then select version 4.7.0
under the version option copy the third
url with min.css as extension and paste
it into your html file as simple as that
i'll let you know about the classes
we'll use while working on the website
now let's start with the programming
part
the first thing we have on our website
is the navigation bar right let me show
it to you again so here you can see we
have a navigation bar we'll first work
on this one only
so let's start writing the code so this
is
the output of a current website so what
we'll do is
we'll minimize the browser and we'll
start writing the code here only
so what we'll do is we'll write here
nav
class is equals to nav bar
then inside this we'll write div
class is equals to
burger
and inside this we'll write
three div tags fine we'll write here div
class is equals to layer one
will close this div
will copy it from here and we'll paste
it again three times
fine
well right here layer 2 and layer 3 is
class then after this particular div tag
we'll add another div tag
with
class as
logo
then inside this we'll use the span tag
we'll write here span class
is equals to logo
logo text
and then we'll
write here
i will use the i tag to make it a little
bit italic so we'll use the class as
far far book fine
we'll write here
style
is equals
to margin
margin right we'll write your margin
right as 0.1
m then we'll write here
similarly we can close this fine
now we have added the book icon to our
website
then what we'll do is we'll write here
again span will use the span tag within
the suspend tag
we'll write here
style is equals to
color
and the color code is
hash
f095d1
so these are the color codes for this
particular website
we'll use them
we have written here f09d51
fine
then what we'll do is we'll write here
font size as
1.1 m and what we'll do next is we'll
write here
before the span tag closes we'll write
here
learning fine
so what we did wrong here is we forgot
to mention comfort here
now we are done with the logo part next
up what we'll do is
we'll write here
div
class is equals to
menu bar we are working on the menu bar
for the hamburger menu so what we'll do
is we'll write here
ul so ul stand for unordered list will
write here class is
list
and inside this we'll use
li tag so we'll write here
class as let's say list items
we'll
write here
a href is equals to hash
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here who
fine
we'll copy this piece of code
we'll paste it again
three or four times we have four
different options we have home we have
courses and then we have pricings
and finally we have about us fine so we
are done with menu as well next up what
we'll do is we'll write the code for
card now so we'll write here div
class is equals to cart
and inside this will write
i
class is equals to
far far
shopping cart for 1x so here we have
used this special class to include the
card icon to a web page
now next up what we'll do is we'll write
here
div
class is equals
to number of
items
and then we'll write here
span
class is equal to let's say nui
now what we'll do is we'll write here 0
inside this fine i hope you guys
understood what we did till now we are
working on the navigation bar only we
have created the navigation bar so this
is the code firstly we have used a class
navbar for this particular navigation
bar then we have used the div tag for
burger menu we have three different
layers layer one layer two and layer
three so this is actually the icon of
burger menu you can see here if we
reduce the size of our website so we
have defined this burger menu and inside
this we have four other options which we
defined later here inside the menu bar
and we have four options right we have
home courses pricings and about us
so we are doing totally right
so till now we did some basic tasks here
right we have added all the navigation
bar elements and the next thing we have
to do is to style our navigation bar
according to the final website it's
pretty simple let's do one thing let's
save it once and check the output now
let's see if it's working so it's
totally working we have a book icon over
here we have comfort learning written
over here we have
cart icon over here and we have zero
written over here fine now we have to
style those elements accordingly to make
it look like this so we are making this
navigation bar so what we'll do is we'll
move to a css file and we'll start
styling by doing some default style
changes to the entire html document
we'll write here
star
margin will be
zero the default margin will be zero
padding will be
zero then we have
box sizing we'll write here border box
and font size will be
20 pixels for default
fine
next up we'll write here
html we'll
now style html document we'll write here
scroll behavior as smooth
and we'll
write here anchor tag we'll write here
text decoration and we'll write a text
declaration as none
and then we'll
style the unordered list we'll write a
ul
we'll write here
list style as
none
fine
basic styling is done let's do some more
for the navigation bar as well what
we'll do is we'll write here
dot nav bar this is the first class we
have used in a html page
we'll write here display is
flex
then we'll write here
justify content as
space between
align
items
as center
height as 10 vh
so 10vh refers to the viewport height it
will take 10 of the total height of the
screen
then we have
background color as
hash
e c e c e c so a little bit of gray
grayish white we can say
then next thing we'll do is we'll style
a logo we'll write here logo and inside
this will write
padding so we will write here padding
left and the padding left will be 2m
next up we'll write here logo
text so this is the next class we'll
write here
font size as 1.5
m
now the next class we have to use is
the menu bar
class so we'll write here
width
as
45 percent
and
margin left as
8.5 m fine
i'll let you know what this m means
in a moment so first we'll do this
styling and all next up we'll write here
dot list
will access the list
and we'll write here inside this
display as
flex
and
justify content as space between
fine next up we have the list items so
we'll write here list items
and we'll of course write here a as well
we'll write here color and the color
will be let's say black
next up what we'll do is we'll write
here
font family as
sense serif font size as
0.9 m
so you must have noticed earlier that
the default font size was 20 pixels so
keep that in mind i'll let you know the
use of m in a moment
next up we'll write here
transition
is 0.4 seconds
and we are good to go with it next up
we'll
write here list items
and we'll write here
hover fine
then we'll write here
color is
black
on hovering the color of the list items
will change to black
now the next thing we'll do is we'll
write here cart
padding right will be
2m
and position will be relative fine
we are done with the card
next up we will write here
cart
number
of items fine
we'll write here
display is
flex
cursor is
pointer we are using repeat we are
styling two different classes here we
are styling the element with classes
cart and the element with classes number
of items fine we'll write here justify
content
to center
align items to center
we'll write here color
is
white
position will be absolute
and then we'll write here left
is 18 pixels
and
right as
okay
sorry will right here left as 18 pixels
and top as
minus 7 pixels
next up we'll write
background
so the background color will be hash f
0 9
d 5
1
so this will be the background color
we'll define the height and width as
well
so height will be
20 pixels and the width will also be
20 pixels fine
the last thing we have to write here is
the border radius
so keep one thing in mind guys while you
are styling all these elements do check
the website after every styling event
because this will let you know what this
particular event does or what this
particular styling property does to that
particular element so do it when you are
writing this code
next up
we'll write here
dot
number of items space dot
knowing so now it was the class we have
already declared
we will write here font size as
0.7 m
the next class we'll be styling is the
shopping cart so we'll style this icon
as well we'll write here
font size as
1.5 m the font size will be equal to
around 30 pixels
then we'll write here
cursor is
pointer
then we'll write here
burger will style the menu as well we'll
write here
height
height will be 28 pixels
width
will be
32 pixels
and then we'll write here
display is none then we'll
style the layers as well we'll write
here dot layer 1 dot layer two
and dot layer
three
now inside this will write
background as
black
height is 4 pixel
margin top is
4 pixels
width as
100
and
we'll write here border radius as 10
pixels
fine
you have seen that hamburger menu you
have seen that icon we were styling that
till now
now you might have noticed here that we
have used m here in the css file so i am
talking about this particular m
or we can say em as well
until now we were using ram or pixel to
define the size of anything while
studying but today we are using m
because m uses the font size for example
if the font size is 30 for the parent
class in this case the font size is 20
the default font size is 20
and the padding is defined as 2m then
the padding will be 40 in that case it
uses the font size to determine the size
of the property
that's why we are using m and if you try
it yourself you will get to know better
so just try using m and you can also use
ram or pixel in this case but for now
we'll use m so this might be a little
bit new for you guys but try it and you
will understand it much better
now save the css file
move back to the browser and you can see
here that we have a navigation bar ready
right it's looking fine
although the icons are not visible the
book icon and the cart icon is not
visible so let's go back and see what's
wrong in this
css file
what we'll do is
we'll move to html file and we'll see if
something is wrong here or not
so nothing is wrong in this case the
error is because we are not connected to
internet so if this error continues just
try to connect your laptop or your pc to
the internet and the icons thing will
work fine so you can see here we have
icons over here we have the book icon we
have the cart icon and what we have to
do is we have to increase the size of
this logo and text a little bit right so
here you can see the comfort learning is
a little bit small
when compared to this particular website
so what we'll do is we'll move to a css
file
and we'll write here instead of 1.5 ram
we'll write here 2m
fine
save it
and here you can see it's
looking fine now
actually it's equal
the difference is because of this scroll
bar we don't have this scroll bar in our
website until now so this is why it
looks a little bit different to you guys
it's working totally fine other than
that
so let's move on to the next part
and the next part of our website is the
background image with the card present
on it right so let's write the code for
this section as well
what we'll do is we'll move to our html
file
and
right here we'll write
section
class is equals to section one
so we are using the section tag to
define a particular section in the web
page
now we'll write here div
class is equals to
banner and here we'll write inside h1
tag
find your
favorite
courses
or course here
then
inside this what we'll do is we'll write
here
a
href is equals
to products so the products file will be
using json for this so
leave it for now we'll write here shop
now so shop now is actually not a button
what we'll do is we'll use a link and
we'll define it later so let's
save it
and move to the browser
open this website and you can see here
it says find your favorite course here
and it says shop now it's not inside the
banner because we need to style this
particular section to make it look like
a website so let's do the styling part
as well
and then we'll talk about it
so we'll move to the css file now
and
here what we'll do
we'll write here dot
section one
height
we'll use the calc function and we'll
write here
100
vh
minus
10 vh so what we are doing is we are
reducing the
navigation bar's height we are reducing
10 viewport height from 100 viewport
height it means that from the whole
screen area it will reduce 10 vh and
give it to that particular image fine
so next up we'll write here
width as hundred percent we wanted to
cover the whole home page so that's why
we are using width as hundred percent
background so we'll add the background
image we'll write a url
and inside this will give the path of
our image
we'll write his images
back one dot png
and we'll write here
center
center cover fine
let's do some more things we'll write
here top as 0
left is
0
z index
is
-1 fine
save it now move to the browser and see
if it's working so here we are we have
our image over here but this banner is
not here till now we'll style it so you
can see the images over here
and one more thing guys we have two
three images over here inside uh images
folder
i'll let you see all of them so here are
the images
and
this is the third one
okay so this is the third one so i was
not sure which one to use but
if you guys liked any of these images do
let us know in the comments below and
we'll use that particular image for now
we'll use my personal favorite image
we'll use background.png save it now
and this is the image we are going to
use in this particular video
so let me know if you have any other
preference or if you know any other
image we'll use that as well
then we'll write here section
1
and we'll style the banner as well for
that we'll write here banner
height
is going to be 170 pixels
width
is going to be
600 pixels
background
is going to be a little bit grayish
so we'll write here rgba
205 comma two double five
comma two double five comma zero point
seven so this is the particular rgba
value and next up
we'll write here
position as relative top is
50 percent
left as
50 of the image
we want the banner to be present at the
center of the image right so next up
will write here
transform
translate
and inside it will write
minus 50 percent
to minus 50 percent
next up we'll write here display is
flex
justify content is
space around
and
flex direction is
column
text align
is
center
and then we have align items as
center
font family is going to be
sensorif again
and
we'll define the z index as well so this
index is going to be
8 in this case
fine
next up we'll inside the h1 tag inside
the banner
so we'll write here banner
h1 and inside this
we'll define the font size as
2m
now
we need to define the
link for shop now so for that we'll
write here
display is
flex
justify content is
center
padding is going to be
1m
space
2.5 m
next up we'll write here
font size as
0.8 m
so this is the font size for the shop
now button which looks like a button but
it is actually a link
so
what we'll do is
we'll define the color of this button is
white
and here the background color is going
to be
h
f 9
0 d 5 1
let's use this color
and we'll write here transition all at
0.3 second
now save it once move to the browser
and you can see it looks fine though the
only thing that is different here in
this website is the color of this link
right or is the color of the shop now
button so we can change the color here
the color is
sky blue
so
let's try to do it so here you can see
the color seems a little bit different
now i don't know the actual value of
this color that's why i'm not sure about
it so what we'll do is
will make it a little
more bright
but
save it now
and you can see it looks same now so
this was the color we found that
now we have to change the color of this
button on hovering over it so what we'll
do is
we'll write here
dot banner a
over
so
the background we are going to change
we'll write here hash
d4
7 6 e
1
okay vani
the color codes are pretty hard to
remember so we are not using this
particular color so we'll change
it to a little bit
blue
save it now move to the browser and you
can see it looks nice right
and the actual website it's a little bit
dull but in our website it looks nice
right it's a little bit dark than the
original color
so that's fine you can change the color
according to you
so
you have seen that this part is also
done it looks nice right till now
the task we did was quite easy
the next thing we have to do is to add
products to our website which are the
courses we'll add those images to our
website using json only so let's do the
html part first let's finish up the html
part and then we'll move on to the json
part so
we'll
move to the html file again and inside
this
now what we'll do is we'll define the
section for
products
so we'll write here
section
class is equals
to
section 2
and id is equals to
products fine we'll use both the class
and id attribute for this particular
section
we'll write here div
class is equals
to title
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here h1
and inside this we'll write courses we
offer
you will again add another div
and inside this will write class is
product
close this div tag
save it and there will be no difference
on the web page you can see here we have
some text present at the bottom which
says courses we offer nothing else let's
add those images now what we'll do is
we'll move to the json file and we'll
add those images with some properties
and pictures so let's move on to the
json file
so here is a json file
products dot json what we'll do is we'll
create an object here so we'll write
here
items
and then we'll use square brackets now
one thing to notice while working on any
json file is that json doesn't let us
use single inverted commas or we have to
use double inverted commas for json file
so if we write here items like this
it won't work see it says this is an
error so in json file we have to use
double inverted comma or double quotes
not single quotes
so now inside the items what we'll do is
we'll create the object for first image
so we'll write here's this
and
then we'll write here id
so id will be
one
we have to use commas to separate the
properties so now we'll write here
fields
colon and inside this we have to use
title so the title for first course will
be
python programming
master course fine
now next thing we'll do is we'll write
here
the price
the price will be let's say one two
three point nine nine dollars
and then we'll write here
image
so inside this will define
several properties for the particular
image we'll write
fields
and
we'll use colon then again we'll use
curly braces we'll write here
file
colon then again we'll use curly braces
we'll write here
url
so you can see it just says there's an
error so we have to remove this curly
braces from here and we have to put it
here now inside url what we'll do is
we'll give
the name of our file so our file is
stored in images folder and the file
name is and
picture name is python.png
fine
so it is working fine now what we have
to do is
we have to put a comma here to again
insert one more
image property so we'll copy it from
here
we'll paste it
for eight times
then what we are going to do here now is
we are going to change the id
the title of the course
so the second course is c plus
master course
and the price for this is let's say
hundred and ten point nine nine dollars
we have to change the path as well this
image is stored as
c plus plus dot png
for the third one we'll write here id as
three
the title is going to be web development
for beginners
the price is let's say
99 because this is a course for
beginners and the file name is
instead of python we'll write here
web1.png
will do the same for all the elements
so next up we'll use ids4
and title as
java programming
master course fine
the price for this course is going to be
149.99
and the file name is
java.png
fine next up we'll write here ids5
the title is going to be digital
marketing
full course
the price is going to be 109.99
and
the name of our image is
digital.png
then we have ids 6 for another course
this course is going to be
advanced
web development
and the price is going to be
comparatively high because this is an
advanced course so instead of
python we'll write here
web 2 because this is the name of our
image
then we have ids 7
and the file name is going to be data
structures and
algorithms
full course
prices you can decide by yourself so
instead of 123 will use 99.99 here and
inside
this will write data.png this is a file
name
then we have the id as 8 for the last
course
the course name is
data science full course
the price is going to be 149.
and image name is
data2
fine
so here you can see it says there is an
error remove this comma because we don't
have any other
image remaining so we are done with the
json file all of this may sound a little
bit tricky to you guys but it is what it
is and we have to keep certain things in
mind for that we can't see these
products in the browser until we are
done with the javascript part as well so
let's do the rest of the html part first
and then we'll see how this works in
javascript save it once go to the
browser
and here you can see we are not able to
see those products till now so what we
are going to do next is we are going to
move to a html file
and inside this we are going to do the
remaining of our html part
so what we will do is we will write here
div
class is equal to cart
sidebar
now we are creating the structure for
our card sidebar it means that when we
use the hamburger menu or when we
decrease the size of our web page or web
browser the cart will open at the site
so we are doing the coding for that
we'll write inside this
div
class is equal to cart
and inside here we'll write
span
class is equal to
close
card now inside this we'll add an icon
we'll write a i
class is equals
far
far times
and we are done with it
now next up what we are going to do is
we are going to write the code inside of
our cart we are going to write here h2
it will say
your cart
and inside this will write div
class is equal to
card content
next up we'll write here div
class is equals
to
total
sum
and we are going to use dollars right so
we'll write here
h1
we'll write here
your total
and
we'll use the dollar sign here
after this we'll write span
class
is equals
to total
amount let's say we are going to change
the class name it will be total amount
we'll close this here and inside this
will write 0 because at this start there
will be no element or no product present
in the cart so the total price will be 0
at the initial point so that's why we
have written 0 here
now we are going to write here div
class is equals
to clear cart
and inside this we are going to create a
button
so the button class will be
btn
clearcard btn so this is going to be a
class
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here
clear cart fine
we are going to do the same for proceed
button as well so we'll write here div
class is equals to
clear cart we are going to use the same
class for both the buttons because i'll
let you know what why we are doing this
at the end of this project
now we'll write here
button
class is equals
to button
clear cart
button
fine we'll write here
proceed
we are done with the cart function
now what we are going to do is we are
going to write some code for the
menu bar side menu bar so we'll write
here
div
class is equal to let's say
menu sidebar inside this will write div
class is equals to close menu
and we'll write here i
class is equals
too far for times
and we'll
close this i tag over here
next up we'll write here after this
class we'll write div
class is equals
to menu let's say this name is menu menu
bar
and inside this will write here
an ordered list class will be
menu list
we'll write here
li class is equals to
menu list items and we'll write here a
href
is equals to hash we'll write your home
and we are good to go fine we'll do the
same for categories pricings and about
us so
we'll copy this
statement
we'll paste it for four times here we'll
write instead of home categories
pricings and about us fine so we are
done with the whole html part now and we
are left with css and javascript only
let's do that as well let's move on to
the css part first and
do the rest of the styling except for
the products we'll do it for products at
the last so let's move on to the css
file first and what we'll do is
so that it will not create any confusion
we'll write here
menu bar because we have to write the
code here between this banner style
property and this menu bar for the
products section so that's why we'll
start writing the code from here and
later we'll add our code here in between
so we'll write here
dot menu
sidebar display will be none
and then we'll write here dot
cart
sidebar
background is going to be
hash
e c e c e c so a little bit grayish
white we can say
we'll write here position as
fixed
write as
zero
and
top is
0
so these are the properties we are
defining
in a css part
then we'll write your width as 450
pixels
and
height is
100 viewport height fine
we'll define the z index as well we'll
write here z index
as 10
transition
is all
at 0.3 seconds and the transition will
be linear
fine next up we'll write here
transform
and inside transform we'll write here
translate x fine so inside here we'll
write
hundred percent
it will go along with the x-axis that's
why we have written it over here we'll
write here overflow
scroll
we are done with it next up we'll
write here dot cart
sidebar and we'll
write here dot cart as well so we'll
define padding here we'll write here
padding as 0 in both
the cases
next up we have
dot cart and
closed cart right so we'll write here
for both of them we'll write here dot
card space close cart the font size is
going to be 1.3 m
padding is going to be 1m
and cursor is going to be
0.2 fine
we'll write here dot
for
times
inside this will write
margin top
as 0.5 m
and we'll write here cart
h2
text
text align will be sent for the heading
of a cart which is your cart
so we'll write your width
is
100 percent
margin bottom is going to be 1m
and
what else we have to do we have to
include the font size as well so we'll
write here
font size is
1.1 in
slightly bigger than the default font
size
then we'll write here
font family
let's use only one
fine
let's use verdana only
so we'll write your vardana
and next up
we'll
write here dot
card
product space dot product
dash image
space img
now we are going to write here something
now we are going to write the code for
all the images present inside the cart
so that's why we are writing here width
as 130 pixels
of that particular image the width is
going to be 130 pixels and the height is
going to be
90 pixel let's say
fine
we are done with this as well
next up we'll write here
dot cart
product
content fine
now we'll write here display as flex
flex direction is
column
and we have
justify content as space around
and align items at the center
we'll write your margin
left is 1m
and
height is
80 pixels
fine
we are done with this as well we'll
write here
dot plus dash minus
this is for increasing or decreasing the
product number in our carts those arrows
you must have remember which we have
seen in the website let me show you
again
so these are the arrows i'm talking
about let me add a product
now go to cart and these are the arrows
i'm talking about right now
so we are going to style those arrows as
well
so we'll write here
display as flex
and
transform
we are going to rotate them so we are
going to write here rotate
at
90 degree
that will look cool
so we'll write here
color is
again
hash
f09d51 so this is the color code for a
particular color
we'll write here font size is 1.5 m
and we'll write here
cursor
as pointer
next up we are going to
do the styling for total sum so we'll
write here
total sum
align at the center
and
margin is
going to be 1m
0
0 point
m and
0 again
so it's for
top bottom left and right everyone
so we'll write here next
clear cut
text align at the center
and we'll write here clear cut
button
now for the cleared car button we'll
write here
background
so background color is going to be
again
that same one
orange we can say or
little bit of orange as well and don't
know the exact name for that color but
it doesn't matter right we can
do anything
we can use any color so
the font color is going to be
white
the border is going to be one pixel
solid
and
white in color for the button right if
we go back to our website and
you can see here this is our button
so we are styling this particular button
now
let's go back here
and we'll write here
padding is
0.5 m
and
1.7 fine
cursor will be
pointer
and
of course transition is going to be
at 0.3 seconds and
linear fine
next up we'll write here
clear cart
dot button
on hovering over it what we want is
we'll write here hover
and we'll define the property now so
we'll
write here
border
okay
we'll write your border murder is going
to be one
pixel thick solid in nature
and of
this color so we'll write here d4
7 6 1 e
fine
on a ring the color will change
obviously so we'll write here this
and now what we are going to do is we
are going to write here background is
transparent
and
color is black
fine
are done with this as well next up we'll
write here overlay for overlay the
height is going to be
100 viewport height
the position is going to be
fixed
the
top is going to be zero similarly the
left
will also be zero
we will define the z index as well we'll
write as z index as nine
and width as
hundred percent
the background color
is going to be
hash
f3
eight
five 1f
fine
so this is for overlay
we'll write here
opacity
as 0.3
and
transition
is all
0.3 seconds and
linear fine so what we are doing is we
are writing the code for this if you
open our cart you can see this
particular area or this particular field
is
a little bit different from what it was
it is a little bit different in color
and opacity is also different the
opacity is 0.3 here we can make it fully
opaque as well so for now we'll use 0.3
only
next up what we are going to do is we
are going to write the property
phone none
will write here none
display is
none fine
now what we are going to do is we are
going to write the css part for tablets
and for mobile screen
so
if you remember
that if we reduce the size of this
chrome browser the size of our website
also reduces and it
becomes like this so to achieve this we
have to write particular css code
for tablet and for phone we have to
define the max width
and we have to do some more things in
there so what we'll do is we'll write
here
at the rate
media
screen and
max width is going to be
768 pixels fine
now inside this we'll write dot logo
we'll change the logo
as well
we'll write here padding left
as
zero
and after this we are going to write
here
dot cart heading right is
2m
after cart we'll write here dot menu bar
so we are going to change all the
properties here almost all the
properties which we will require so
we'll write a display as none the menu
bar will disappear
we'll write here dot burger
and inside this will write
margin left the burger sign will come
into existence now
we'll write here
2m for the margin left for display
we'll write your block
next up we have to do something for
section 1 and for product section as
well so we'll write here dot
section one
and we'll write here dot
banner h1
so we'll write here font size is
1.5 m
and we'll write here dot
banner
a
we are going to change the size of
shop now button so we'll write here
font size is 0.6 m
and padding is
1m and
2m
fine
we are done with this as well next up
we'll write here
dot section
2
note
title and we'll write here h1
inside this will write font
size is
1.5 m
so we haven't defined the section two
and title styling part yet we'll define
it later but we'll write the code for
that as well now next up we'll write
here
menu sidebar
display is going to be block
position is going to be
fixed
left is going to be 0 top is going to be
0 so we'll write here left is going to
be 0
and top will also be 0
then we have
width as
100 percent
height is 100 report height
and
z index is
11.
background is going to be
gray again so we'll write here ec ecec
then we'll write here
overflow is
hidden
and
transform
is
translate so we'll write here minus
hundred
percent
and
transition is again same will write a
0.3 s and
linear fine
next up we'll write here menu as menu
bar
and inside here we'll write
display is flex height is 80 percent
justify content at the center
and we are done so next up we'll write
here menu
list will change the style of menu list
as well
so we'll write here
height height is going to be
100 percent
then we'll write here display as flex we
are rewriting the code again and again
but each time we are doing it for
different class we are doing it for
different element
so keep these things in mind
and we'll write here flex
direction
is
column
align items at the center
and just
define content
justify content is space around now it's
time to do it for menu sidebar for menu
sidebar
and for close menu both will use the
same styling properties
we'll write your position
as absolute
right is going to be 30 pixels
font size is going to be
1.4 m
and after this we'll write
dot
menu list
items
and we'll write here
color
is hash
f09d51 the default color we are using
till now
and lastly we'll write here
dot
menu dash list
items space a on
over will write here
color is
ash
f5 7b
09
fine so here's a mistake we have
placed colon here twice
we'll remove it
and now we are done with the tablet part
so we have to change the style of almost
all the elements we are done with the
tablet part next up we have to
write the same code for mobile part as
well
and we'll write here at the rate media
screen
so
we'll write here and max width
is going to be
480 pixels
now what we'll do is we'll write here a
strict font size
is going to be 16 pixel here we have
changed the font size for the whole
entire html document we have done it
because we have used m in place of ram
or pixels in this case or in this video
so that's why we have changed the size
here because we want the
screen to be smaller in size right if we
go back here you can see
the font size is 16 by default and if we
do it you can see the font size changes
for each and every element right to
achieve this we have to use m in place
of pixel or ram we can say
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here dot
section
1
dot
banner
and we'll write here
width as
280 pixels
for both
and we'll write your height
as 100 pixels fine
you can see here the height of this
image is 100 pixel or we can say the
height of this banner is 100 pixel and
the width is 280 pixels so this is why
we are changing the style of all these
elements because we want all these
elements to fit inside a smaller screen
that's why we have to change the height
or we have to change the width as well
now what we'll do is
we'll write here
section
one dot
banner
we'll write here h1
inside this will write font size
as
1.2 m
display is going to be
now we don't have to use display here i
guess let's
leave it
so we are done with this next up we'll
write the code for burger we'll write a
burger margin left is going to be 1 m
for mobile
for mobile the display is going to be
block
and the width is going to be
30 pixel
fine
we'll do the same for card sidebar
we'll write here
width
as 100 of the screen the card will take
whole screen and we'll write here at the
last for product
so for product we'll write here
margin is
zero display is flex
justify content at the center
align items at the center
and flex direction is going to be column
so we have covered almost every html
element in the css file we are done with
the styling for everything except
products will style them later let's
move on to the javascript part now and
see how we can fetch those products
so we cannot witness every style change
right now but we'll witness them while
covering the javascript part
so let's move on to the javascript part
first and we'll start with the card
section and the hamburger menu thing
so save it and if you want to witness
the changes we made you can go here and
you can see the cart is not opening
because we need to write the javascript
part for that and everything else
remains the same if we reduce the size
of our browser you can see we have a
menu over here we can increase the size
and we have
our image adjusting itself accordingly
so we can use it and it's quite
responsive as well
let's move on to the javascript part now
we'll open the javascript file
and
first of all we'll access all the html
elements with the query selector method
so we have several html elements right
here you can see we have
several elements present in our html
file we are going to access few of these
elements so what we are going to do is
we are going to write here
construct
is equals
to document
dot query selector
we are going to write here
nav space dot cart
then we are going to do the same
for a long
time so what we are going to do is we
are going to copy paste this piece of
code again and again
for several times we are going to change
the name of
variables so we'll write here
card sidebar
and instead of this we'll write here
dot cart sidebar
the next one will write here
dot
close card and here the variable name
will change to
close card
fine
next up we'll take another variable as
burger
and here we'll change
the query
from nav dot card to
dot burger fine
next up we have menu sidebar
so we'll write here menu sidebar and
here what we'll do is we'll write here
dot
menu
sidebar
fine next up we have
close menu
and here we'll
write
close menu again
after close menu we have cart items
total
so we'll write here cart
items
total and
we will
use noi
then we have total amount as well so
we'll write here total amount
and here we'll write card price total
we have to access a lot of elements
so
then we'll write here cart
ui
and
for this we'll access
cart sidebar and cart so we will write
here dot cart
sidebar space
card
fine
then we have the total sum so we'll
write here total sum
we'll put a dot over here
and here we'll write
total diff
then we have the clear button so we'll
write here clear
button and here we'll write
clear card button
then finally we have
variable name card content
to access everything present in the cart
so we'll write here dot cart
content
here we'll write
card content
so these are our 12 variables and we
have accessed almost every element
present in a html file which we are
going to need further so i hope you guys
understood this we have used the query
selector method to access all the html
elements here in the javascript part
now next up we'll take two empty arrays
so we'll write here
let
cart
is equals to an array
and we'll write here let
buttons dom
and it's again going to be an array
fine
now we'll first create some events to
open and close the cart for that we'll
write here
cart dot
ad event listener
will add a click event here
and we'll write here function
now inside this will write card dot
we'll write cart
sidebar
dot style
dot
transform is equals
to
translate
zero percent fine so this is we are
changing the style of card sidebar
next up we'll write here
const body overlay will take a variable
of named const body overlay we'll write
here document
dot
create element
and we'll write here
div inside this fine
next up what we'll do is
we'll write here
body overlay
dot
class list
dot add
and we'll write here
overlay
fine
we'll use the settimeout method so we'll
write here
set timeout
okay we have written here sst so we'll
write a set timeout
and then we'll create an anonymous
function and inside here what we'll do
is we'll write
document dot query selector
and inside here we'll write body then
we'll write here append and we'll append
body overlay
so we'll write here body overlay fine
and the time will pass here is
going to be 300 milliseconds
we are done with this function we'll add
another event so what we'll do is we'll
write here close
cart
dot ad event listener
now we are closing the card so we'll
write here
click
then we'll
create a function
and we'll write here
card sidebar
dot
style dot
transform and again we'll translate it
to 100
previously we did for zero percent and
now we'll translate it to 100 again so
we'll write here translate and we'll
pass hundred percent inside the
brackets here
next up we'll again use the body overlay
variable so we'll copy this from here
and we'll paste it here we'll of course
change the create element value so
instead of create element we'll write
here
document
dot query selector
and we'll write here
dot
overlay
fine
next up we'll write here document
dot query selector
and we'll write here body
dot
remove child will remove
body overly from here so we'll write
here
body overlay fine
we are good to go save it now
and go to the browser
so here you can see on clicking the cart
a cart is working totally fine now we
are in this particular program so we are
in our website which we are creating
right now
this is the original website this is the
final product so leave it and we are
going to work on our website only so
here you can see our cart is working
totally fine
now we can open or close our cart and we
have two options over here one is for
clearing the entire cart and the other
one is for proceeding further
next up we'll add some more events for
the hamburger menu now how to open or
close that menu and all so for that
we'll move to a javascript file again
and we'll write here
burger dot
add event listener
and we'll add a click event we'll write
here click
we'll write here
function and then we'll write here
menu sidebar dot
style dot
transform and what we are going to do is
we are going to translate
again we are going to translate it to
zero percent
now the same thing we have to do for
this as well we'll write here burger
dot add event listener
inside here we'll
write click
and then we'll write a function
which will again do the same task it
will translate to minus hundred percent
we'll write here menu sidebar dot
style dot
transform and
we are again going to translate it to
minus hundred percent now
fine
save it
and go to the browser
now
if we decrease the size of a web page or
if we decrease the size of a browser you
can see
okay let me decrease it first so you can
see the hamburger menu over here and on
clicking it's not working right now so
let's inspect those elements once
and there's no error but
let me check if there's any mistake okay
so we have to write here
close menu
and now i guess it will work fine
we'll save it again and we'll move to
the browser
reduce the size click on this hamburger
menu
and you can see it's working totally
fine now
right so this part is also done now what
we have to do next is we have to create
a class to get those products from the
json file so keep your eyes open now
guys we'll see how it actually works so
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a class named
product
so this is a class
we will write here a sink i hope you are
already aware of async and await
so we'll write here get product
and this is a function
we'll write here const
response is equals to await and
while awaiting it will fetch
products dot
json
fine
then we'll create a variable we'll write
here const
data is equals to await
response dot
json
fine
next up we'll write
products is equals to
data dot items
and we'll write
products is equals
to
products
dot map function we are going to use so
we'll write here again item
then we'll use arrow function we'll
write the body of this function here
we'll write here
const inside this will pass
title and price of the product
and we'll write here item
dot
fields
fine
similarly we'll do the same for id as
well inside curly braces we'll write id
and we'll write here
item dot cis
then we'll write here
const
image now we are fetching the image so
we'll write here
item dot
fields dot
image
dot
fields
we are actually giving the path right if
you see here in the json file you can
see inside items we have says fields
then inside fields we have title price
image and then inside image we have
fields file and url so we'll access each
of them
now we'll write here after fields
dot file
dot url
and
lastly we'll write here return
title
price
id and
image fine
finally we'll write here after this
return
products
cool
now what we are doing here is we are
getting the details of all the products
and storing them inside separate objects
so we have all the objects present over
here all those images were actually
stored inside the local storage
and now we can fetch them from that
particular storage now we'll create
another class for the user interface of
the product so if you save it now and go
to the browser
you will see no difference over here
because it's not working as of now if
you go to inspect elements and console
you can see it says
length mismatch
it's because of the live server so
there's no pro error over here
now we'll create another class for the
user interface of the products we'll add
those products to the cart and we can
delete them from the cart we'll do
everything inside one single class so
let's do it
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here
class let's say the class name is ui
and we'll write here
display products and we'll write here
products
then we'll
right here inside this let result be a
variable
and
we'll leave it empty over here
next line we'll use the forage loop so
we'll write here products
dot
for each
and inside this will
create an arrow function
so we'll write here
const
product div
let's say is a variable and then we'll
write here
document dot
create element
again we are going to create an element
so we'll write here div
and
after this
what we are going to do is we are going
to write here product
div dot
inner html
is equals to
now the main part starts so inside this
we'll write
div
class is equals
to product card
and
then we'll write
img
we'll add the image so here we'll write
mg src is equals to
dollar
product
dot
image we are going to fetch it
and instead of alt
in place of alt we'll write
alt as
product
in the next line we'll use the span tag
again we'll write here span class
is equals to
add to
cart and we'll then write here
data id is equals to
product dot id
will close this tag will close this span
tag we can say in the next line we'll
use the i tag we'll write a i class is
equals to
far far
cart
plus
for one x
now what we are doing is we are going to
show the number of items present in our
cart over the cart icon that's why we
are doing all this so here what we'll do
is we'll write style
is equals to margin
dash
right
margin right is going to be 0.1 m
and
font size is going to be
1 m
fine
close this as well close the i tag as
well
and in the next line
right here
at to cart
so this pen tag is finally we are going
to close it
now
this is a single tag
i have written it in such a way because
i don't want it to create any sort of
confusion for you guys so the span tag
starts from here and goes till here
now we are remaining with some more part
of it so in the next line what we are
going to do is we are going to write
here div
class is equals
product name and here we'll write
dollar
product dot
title and we are going to close this div
tag
in the next line we are going to write
div again
class is going to be product pricing
and inside here we'll write
product
dot
price
and we are going to close this div tag
here
close
the first div tag as well
and
omega 2 in the next line what we are
going to do is we are going to write
here
const
p is equals to
document dot
query selector
and inside this will write
dot
product we are going to access the
element with product as class
or we are going to access the product
query
then we'll write here p dot
append
equal to
product div what we are doing is any
item we are adding to cart is we are
going to append that item inside the
card so that's what we are doing till
now
now the next thing we are going to do is
we are going to write here a function
get buttons
basically a constructor we can say we
will write here const
buttons
we'll write your cons buttons is equal
to
document
dot
query selector
we have to write a query selector all
and then we are going to write here
inside this
dot add to
cart
fine we have been through all these
query selector methods previously so i
don't think that this is going to create
any sort of problem for you guys
so let's move ahead and
we'll write here array dot
from
we'll write here buttons
then we'll write here buttons
dom
is equals to buttons we are going
to pass the value of buttons to buttons
norm then we'll write buttons dot
for each
and inside here we'll write
button and we are going to create an
arrow function over here
here what we'll do is we'll write here
let
id is equals
to
button
dot
data set dot id in the next line we'll
write let's
in cart
is equals
card dot
find and we are going to pass item
to this function
so we are going to
write inside here
item
and again an arrow function
will write here item dot id
triple is equals
to id
fine
we are going to check the condition here
if we write here if
in cart
then we'll write here
btn dot
inner html
is equals
to in
cart so what we are doing is if we have
added the
product to cart already then the button
will change
as we have seen earlier that on adding
the product once to the card the button
will change to in cart from add to cart
so this is what we are doing here
next up we'll write here
button
dot disabled
is equals to true we are going to
disable that button once the product is
added to cart fine
next up
we'll write here
button dot add event listener
and we are going to create an event
we'll write here click
and
let e here
then we'll
use the arrow function
and we'll write it here e dot
current target dot
inner html is equals to
in cart
then we'll write it e dot
current target dot in html okay we'll
write here e dot current target dot
style dot
color
is equals
to white
e dot
current target dot
style dot
pointer events equals to none
and
we are done with it next up we are going
to store the products in the cart so for
that what we are going to do is
we are going to write here let
cart item is equals to
so we are going to use a little bit of
json now
we'll write here
dot storage
dot
get storage products
will write a id
comma
amount
and the amount is going to be one
we'll write here
card dot
we are going to push the cart item to
the cart
so we will write here cart item
and then we'll write here storage we are
going to store it inside the cart so
we'll write here storage dot safe cart
and we'll pass cart over here
fine now we have to calculate the total
and we have to set the total items as
well so for that we'll write here
this
dot
set card values
we'll write here
cart
and to display those cart item we have
to write here this dot
add card item and we have to add that
card item so we'll write here
this dot
add cart items
item
and will
pass
cart item over here
fine
we are done with the working of cart as
well next up what we are going to do is
we are going to change the total value
of cart we are going to change the value
of cart on increasing or decreasing the
card products
so first of all we have to write here
set cart values and we have to pass cart
over here we have to write here
let's say we have a variable
temp total so this is going to be a
temporary variable we'll write here time
total is equals to 0
and we'll take another variable
for that we'll write here
item total
so item total is also going to be 0. now
we'll map this card so for that we'll
write here card dot map
will write your item
use
arrow function so for that we'll write
here
temp total
plus is equals to
item dot
price
into
item dot
amount
so this is how we are going to get the
total amount and then we'll write here
item basically we are swapping all of
that so we will write here item total
is equal to
item
dot
amount we have to add these two values
so we'll write here item total plus is
equals to item dot amount
fine
now we'll
write here
parse float
and we are going to change these values
just like percent we have parse float as
well so inside pass float we'll write
tam total
dot
to fixed
and we are going to fixed it until two
decimal units fine
next up we'll write here cart items
total dot
inner html
is equals to
items total
and we'll write here cart
price total
dot inner html is equals to
parse float
we'll write here temp
total
dot
two fixed and we'll fix it up to two
decimal units fine
next up we'll write here
add
cut item
now we'll write here card item
and inside this will write let
cart item
ui
is equals
to document dot
create element
we'll write here div
we'll write here cart item
ui
dot
inner html
is equals to we are again going to do
the same task
so we are going to use the backtick for
that so here we'll write
div
class
is equals
to card product
and we'll write here
div
class is equals to product image
we'll write here img src
is equal so we are going to fetch the
image again so we'll write here dollar
and inside this will write
cart item dot
image
and alt will be
product in this case as well
top we are going to close this div tag
and
we are going to start another div tag
here so we'll write here div
class is equals
to cart
product
item
sorry card product content we can say
and then
we'll write here
in the next line
div
class
is equals
to
card product name
we'll write here inside h3
tag
so inside h3 tag we'll write
dollar
cart item dot
title
and we are going to close this h1 tag
over here h3 tag sorry
h3 tag over here then we'll close this
div tag as well
we are again going to create another div
tag this time we are going to write the
class
as
card product
price we are going to fetch the price
now
we'll write here
again
h3
so our price is in dollars so we'll use
dollars for now we can use rupees here
as well so we can write here
cart item dot
price the price is going to be in
dollars then we'll
close this tag
and we are also going to close the div
tag here fine
in the next line
we are going to create the product
remove card
so we are going to create a div tag for
that and the class is going to be cart
product remove data
id is going to be cart id so we will
write here cart
item dot id
and then we'll write here
href is equals
to hash
and style is going to be
color is going to be
red
and then we'll write here remove
i'm going to close the
anchor tag and then the
div tag
fine
so we are done with this
till now then we are going to again
close this particular div tag we used
previously
now what we are going to do is we are
going to change the number of products
so we are going to use here class
is equals to
plus minus
and here we'll write
inside the itec
class
is equals to
for for
angle
left
add amount
fine
this is going to be the class
and
the data id is going to be
cart item id so we are going to write
here
data id is equals to
dollar
and inside this will write
cart item id
dot id
and then we are going to
close this stack and we are going to
close the
i tag here
fine
next up we are going to use the span tag
again we are going to write here
span
class is equals
to
number of items
and we'll
close this tag here we'll write
dollar
cart item
dot
amount
we are
going to close the span tag here so
we'll write here slash span
in the next line we are again going to
use
data id
and here what we'll do is we'll write
here
dollar
and we'll write here
cart item dot
id
we are going to close the i tag again
and in the next line we are going to
close the div tag
and one more div tag fine
now we are done with it
let me close this first and
next up we'll append this card content
to the cart item ui so we'll write here
card
content
dot
append
and inside this will pass
cart item
ui
fine
so here you can see we are going to
close
close this so this is the closed one
and inside here we'll write
setup app
again a
constructor we are going to write here
cart
is equals
to storage dot
get card
we'll write this
dot
set cart values
cart here
and then we'll write card dot map
inside this will write item
and inside the body we'll write
this
dot
add cart item
item
fine i hope you guys are getting this
next up we'll write the cart logic here
we'll write a cart logic
and we'll write here
clear button
dot add event listener
we are going to
create an event again we'll write here
click
comma a function
inside this will write this dot
clear cut we are going to call this
function over here
now we have
to write the logic for
remove button
so
we'll do it here
we'll write here
card content dot ad event listener
click
com event
and we'll write here
inside this
if
event dot
target
dot
class list
dot
contains
got
product remove
then
we'll again create a variable let's say
the variable is let
okay we have made a mistake over here
we have to close this bracket here
and then we have to write here
let id is equals
to event dot
target dot
data set dot
id
the next line will write
this dot
remove item and will pass id here fine
in the next line we'll write here let
div
is equals to event
dot target
dot
parent element
and we are going to use parent element
for quite some time now so we are going
to write here dot
parent element again
for four times so we'll write here
parent element dot
parent element so we have written it
four times here
in the next line we'll write here
div dot
remove child
and we'll write here event dot
target
dot
will copy it from here
and we'll paste it here fine
now in the next line
we are going to close this bracket
and we are going to start writing here
elsif
event dot
target
dot
class list
dot
contains
add amount
then what we are going to do is we are
going to use the id variable again we
are going to write here let id is equal
to
event dot target
dot
data set dot id
let
item
is equals to
card dot find
will pass item here and
we'll use the arrow function so we'll
write here item dot
id
equals to id
fine then we'll write here
item dot
amount
plus plus so we are going to
increase the amount
of items then what we are going to do is
we are going to write here storage dot
safe cart
and we are going to pass card here
will write here this
dot set card values
card
we'll write a event dot
target
dot
next element sibling dot inner html
is equals to item dot
amount
fine
now we are going to
use another elsevier so we'll write here
elsif
event
dot
target
dot
class list dot contains
reduce amount
so we are going to change the number of
products in our cart
so for that what we'll do is we'll write
here
let id is equals to
event dot data set
even dot
target dot data set
dot
id
fine
and item will
be let item is equals to
card dot find
item
item dot id
triple equals
to id
if
we are again going to use an if
statement so we'll write here item dot
amount
is
greater than 1 if the number of items is
greater than 1
then
item dot
amount
minus minus
and store it
inside the cart so we are going to write
here
storage dot safe cart
and we'll pass card here
then we'll write here this dot
set card values
and we'll again pass cart here
in the next line we'll write here
event dot
target
dot
previous element sibling
html
is equals to item dot
amount
and finally we'll write here else
and inside the else what we'll do is
we'll write here
this dot
remove item
and we'll pass the id we'll write here
let
div is equals
to event dot
target we are basically targeting the
events we are creating conditions for
certain different events like when the
user increases the number of products
and the user decreases the number of
products and if the user removes the
product from the card so we are writing
the code for that so we'll write a event
dot target dot
parent element
and we'll write here parent element
again for
four times
fine
we'll write here div dot
remove child
and inside this will write even dot
target dot
parent element for four times again
it will check each parent element
so
here we are done with it
next up
we have to create two functions for add
amount
and for reduce amount so what we are
going to do is
we are going to
write here
add amount
and we'll write here
const
add button is equals to
document dot
query selector
all
inside this will pass dot
add amount
fine
we'll write here add button
dot
for each
and we'll write here inside this
return dot add event listener
and we'll add an event over here we'll
write a click
comma event
will pass event here
and then we'll write here
like this
let
id
is equals to
event dot
current target dot
data set
dot id fine
we'll write here
card dot
map
and will pass item over here will right
here again
arrow function and inside this what we
are going to do is we are going to write
here
item dot
amount plus plus
storage dot
safe cart we are going to pass cart here
we will write here this dot
set card values
we are again going to set the cart
values and
we'll again use
amount ui
a new variable and we'll
write here event dot
current target
dot
parent element
dot
children
fine so we are targeting the parent
element along with the children
so we'll write here
amount ui
dot in html is equals to item dot
amount
so we have forgot to mention here
if
item dot id
is equals
to id
then do it
fine now we are going
to do the same thing
for reduce amount as well so we'll write
here
reduce amount
and inside this will write
const
reduce button
is equals
to document
dot
query selector all
and we are going to
pass here dot
reduce amount
fine
we'll write here reduce
button dot
for each
then we'll pass button over here and
we'll use the arrow function again
finally we'll write here
button dot add event listener
click
event
let id
is equals to
event dot
current
current target
dot
data set
dot id
fine
we'll write here card dot map will map
it to cart
and we'll write here item
then again we'll write here if
time item dot id
triple equals to id
then we'll
write here item amount minus minus so
we'll write here item dot amount minus
minus
and if
item dot
amount is greater than
zero then what it will do
it will
store it inside the
local storage so we'll write a storage
dot safe cart
and we'll write here
cart
then we'll write this
dot
set cart values
cart
construct
amount ui
is equals
to event
dot
current target
dot
parent element
dot children
amount ui dot
inner html is equals to item dot
amount fine
again we'll write here else
else what will happen we'll write here
event
dot
current target dot
parent element so here instead of parent
element we'll write
remove child and we'll write here
event
dot current target
dot
parent element dot
parent element fine
in the next line we'll write this
dot
remove item and we'll pass id here
we are done with this part as well next
up we have to clear the card so for that
we'll write here
clearcard
will again do something for that we'll
write here let cart item is equal
scot.map
inside this will write item
implies item dot id
card item dot
we'll again use the for each loop here
we'll write here this then we'll provide
id here
and we'll write here
this dot
remove item
will pass the id over here
then we'll write your const
product will create
a new variable here we'll write here
document dot
query selector all and we'll write here
dot
card product
right here card product
dot
for each
for each item what we are going to do is
we are going to create
an arrow function here and we are going
to write if item is true if item is
there
then item dot parent element
dot
remove child
will remove the item
now we have to remove the item so for
that we'll write here remove
item and we'll pass id to that item
we'll write here
card will update the value of cart as
card dot filter
we'll write here item
and then we'll write here item dot id
not
equals
to id this
dot
set card values
and will update the card then
similarly we'll again write here storage
dot
safe cart
and we'll pass
cart here
then we'll write here let
button is equals to this
dot
get single button
we'll write your id
and we'll change the button style we'll
write here button dot style dot
pointer events
is equals to
unset
then we'll write a button dot
inner html
is equals to
mactic
i
class will be
far far card plus
we are going to close the i tag here
and we'll write here
add to
cart
fine
next up we'll write here
get single button we'll pass id over
here
and we'll write the code for here we'll
write here let
btn
then we'll write here
buttons dome dot
for each
for each button
what it will do is
we'll check if
button dot
data set dot id
is equals to id
then
equals to
button
fine
here we will return
button
now save it
save this program go to browser
and this is our website go to browser
and you can see nothing is visible till
now we have to write a little more code
to make everything visible here now we
have to store the data in local storage
so that on refreshing the web page we
don't lose the data so what we'll do is
we'll go back to a javascript file and
we'll write here
class
storage
equals to
save products
we'll pass products here
and then we'll open curly braces and
we'll write here local storage
dot
set item
and inside this will write
products dot
comma
json dot
stringify
products
and we are parsing the products from our
json file now
next up we'll write here
static
get storage products
we'll pass the id here
and we'll write here let
products is equals to
json
dot
parts
storage dot
get item
and we'll pass
products
find in the next line we'll write
return
products dot
find
will write your item
item dot id is equals to id
fine
next up will again write here static
save card
now we are saving the products
in our cart so we'll write here
local storage dot
set item
inside here will pass
cart
and here we'll write
json
dot
stringify
and we'll pass
cart over here
next up we'll write here static
get card we are getting the items from
the cart we'll write here return
local storage dot
get item
cart
here will write question mark we'll pass
the json file here we'll write here json
dot
parse
local storage dot
get item
from the
cart
fine
here we have to
put a square bracket a pair of square
brackets
and lastly we have to write a few lines
of code so we'll write here document
dot add event listener
and we'll write here
dom
content
loaded so we are adding
one more event to our javascript file
which is the dom content loaded so
we have to write here dom content loaded
and here we have to write
inside the
function const
products
is equals
to new product
and we'll write here
const ui is equals to
new ui
now we have to show cart from local
storage so we'll write here
ui dot
setup app
and
we'll write here
products dot
get product
dot
then
and inside this will write
products
equal
implies this
ui dot
display
display products will write here
products
storage
dot
save products and we'll pass
products here as well
fine
we'll write here dot then
we are using promises
so
here we'll write
ui dot
get buttons
and ui dot
cart logic
fine
now the javascript part is done we have
used json here to make our web page more
responsive towards several aspects apart
from that we have used json for adding
products to our website as well now we
are left with one more task only
let's do it and then we'll see the final
outcome of this extended code
so
we'll move to the css file and we'll
start starting the products part let's
try if it's working or not let's save
this piece of code and go to
browser click on shop
now and it's not working we can see
okay
it says it's failed to load the resource
refresh it and you can see now it's
working totally fine we have all our
product images over here we have all of
our products we can add them to cart and
we can use the cart as well so the last
thing we have to do is to use products
now
now we have to style those products so
for that we'll move to a css file
so here's our css file
and inside this
we have
to write here
so we have put a comment over there
when we were not here so we have to
style the products over here so for that
we'll write here
dot section 2
dot
title
and text align at the center
then we'll write here section 2
dot
title
h1
and the font size is going to be
1.8 m
the margin is going to be
1.3 m then we have to write the code for
products here so we'll write your dot
product
and inside this will write
margin as
0.5 m
we have to write here margin
we'll write a 0.5 m and auto
max width
is going to be 1300 pixels
display is going to be grid
grid column
is going to be so his is going to be
grid column gap and it is going to be
2m
then we'll write here
grid row gap
and grid row gap is going to be 2m as
well
then we'll write here
grid
template
columns and we'll write here repeat
we are going to create a grid for our
products right so we'll write here auto
fit
comma min max
we'll write here 350 pixels
and
one draw
fine next up we'll write here dot
product
card
and now we are going
to write here text align as center
position as relative
max width of the grid is going to be 350
pixels
and overflow is going to be
hidden
next up we'll write here
product card image
we'll write here height
as
300 pixels
width
as 300 pixels
and
transition is
0.3 seconds linear
fine
similarly we'll do the same for product
name and product pricing so we'll write
here
product
name
comma
product
pricing
margin for them is going to be
0.3 m
we'll write here dot
product
pricing and the color of the product
pricing is going to be
the one we have been using till now so
we'll write here f 0
9 d 5 1
then we have
to write the code for add to cart button
so we'll write here add
to cart
we'll write here
align items to the center
justify the content to the center
and color is going to be white
padding is going to be 0.2 m and
1 m
fine height is going to be
30 pixels
background
is going to be
the same
f9
d51
position is going to be
absolute
right is going to be zero
transform
it's going to be
translate
along the x-axis to
100 percent
bottom is
going to be
80
pixels
you have to put a comma here
bottom is going to be 80 pixels
transition is going to be
0.3 seconds again and linear
cursor is going to be point
fine
then we have to write few more lines so
we'll write a product card
we'll write here hover
and we'll add add to cart here
so we'll write here transform
translate x
zero percent
we'll write your
product card
on hovering over the image so we'll
write here over
img
opacity will change to zero point
seven
let's try it and finally we'll write
here
dot add to cart
hover
and here we'll write
color as
black
fine we are done with it we have styled
the products as well we are now done
with the website
save it
move on to the browser and let's face
the truth now
so you can see it's not working as of
now refresh the web page and
the products looks really big now
what we have to do is we have to move
over here and we have to
see what's wrong over here
this was a mistake and it's done
let me see what's wrong
something is not right here everything
seems fine but we have to search for the
error
so if we see here max width is fine the
max width for product is fine
let's try to do this thing we'll write
here this
save it now and i know that this is the
error we did
so such small errors sometime costs us
way more
go to the browser and you can see our
website is fine now try adding the
products to the cart
you can see the products are in the cart
we can increase the number of products
the total is increasing with that
and
it's working totally fine click on the
clear card button and it's not working
click on the proceed button and it
clears the card
a simple solution for this
go to the html file
right clear cart over here and
proceed over here save it
move to the browser
try adding products to the cart
go to the cart
increase the numbers everything is fine
proceed it's not working clear cart and
the cart is clear
now that we have done so many things on
the website here is a task for you guys
we have left the proceed button inside
the card with no functionality we did it
with purpose i want you guys to do
something creative with it you can take
the user further to the login or sign up
page and you can use regular expressions
to validate the form upon successful
validation you can further take the user
to the payment page i want you guys to
do that part and let us know in the
comments below if you are facing any
problems or if you have any doubts
regarding that as we saw in today's
video how easy it was to create a
website for different courses using
javascript on that note if you are
looking for free course with
certifications you can check out skillup
by simplylearn a great resource of free
courses on various technologies that
will help you get ahead in your career
check out the link in the description
below to know more so if this video
helped you anyhow do give it a thumbs up
if you have any doubts do let us know in
the comments below share it with your
friends and don't forget to subscribe
simply learn thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here